Selena Gomez reunites with her Wizards  of Waverly Place castmates for her TV  brothers wedding we've been waiting for  this for a long time Selena's co-star  David Henry is a married man the 27 year  old actor tied the knot to Maria hill on  Friday in an intimate ceremony on Sunday  Selena took say Instagram sharing sweet  pics with her on-screen family at  David's wedding she pinned an emotional  message to the groom that read very much  in my feelings about my big brother  getting married even though we for sure  knew it would be him first I learned  from my friends I grow from them to ear  with the right group of people  [Music]